las protestas en sídney y melbourne
fueron masivas cientos de personas se
tomaron las calles para manifestarse en
contra de las restricciones impuestas
por los gobiernos estatales debido al
rebrote de la variante delta de kobe 19
en el caso de sydney la ciudad completa
ya un mes en confinamiento en melbourne
vive su quinto confinamiento desde que
inició la pandemia y el tercero este año
en estas manifestaciones hubo
alteraciones del orden público y la
policía hizo uso de la fuerza en sydney
57 personas fueron capturadas y se
impartieron 90 multas por violar las
medidas sanitarias en melbourne seis
personas fueron capturadas y se
impartieron 74 multas
sídney en las últimas 24 horas registró
163 casos nuevos de kobe lo que llevó a
la ciudad a tener mil 703 casos activos
en melbourne tiene una situación
diferente con menos casos en las últimas
24 horas registró 12 casos nuevos y el
estado de victoria tiene 169 casos
activos las autoridades ahora temen que
estas aglomeraciones estas
manifestaciones eleven el número de
casos tanto en sydney como en melbourne